en numéro 5 on a agriculteur salarié
ouvrier agricole
ça arrive tant que ça arrive et ça
arrive voilà en numéro 4 à votre avis
agent d'entretien de locaux
aide apprenti Employé polyvalent de
cuisine
[Musique]
Jean-Michel viticulteur arborécole
salariés et cueilleurs
en premier
et on a on a il en a un petit peu parlé
[Applaudissements]
énorme pénurie ils ont beaucoup de mal
pour recruter et surtout depuis le covid
en fait les gens ont découvert qu'on
pouvait voilà qu'on pouvait aménager son
temps de travail
Dieu décide que malheureusement
la saison s'arrête pour vous et vous ne
pouvez plus travailler à la télévision
on vous a fait un petit un petit
classement enfin montrer des métiers que
nos chroniqueurs pourraient
éventuellement reprendre si par malheur
il venait à être licencié
alors j'ouvrirai une librairie salon de
thé à Royan
c'est pas très original plus vu par
exemple dans un sex-shop
c'est vrai que j'ai des compétences
librairie salon de thé à Royan
donc
vous ne pratiquez de sexe d'accord très
bien très bien je serai Fauconnier au
Puy du Fou
qu'est-ce qu'il faut cogné
déjà pour cogner Jean-Michel
Sophie ouais j'adore
j'adore j'adore le moyen-âge j'adore
toutes les POP médiévales et j'adore les
rapaces donc je ferai ça ah bah vous
êtes heureuse à la télévision
[Rires]
et vous franchement j'ai l'image là en
cuir avec le gant tout ça
doucement
je me visuais je me projette
je lance le faucon sur vous voyez très
bien
merci arrêtez vous maintenant
c'est c'est
lourdes
insupportable j'aurais une agence
matrimoniale Jean-Michel
ça revient de plus en plus en fait les
gens désert tout ce qui est compagnie et
il se retourne vers l'agence
patrimoniale du sérieux mais sérieux
voilà alors qui pourrait faire ça
moi je suis très nul pour me trouver un
mec évidemment puisque je n'en ai pas
mais en revanche j'ai déjà fait plein de
mariages genre j'ai vraiment quatre
couples d'amis que j'ai marié qui sont
mariés aujourd'hui toujours marié pas
divorcé avec des enfants donc je trouve
que je suis assez bonne dans ça et pour
le coup c'est vrai que ça revient en
force il y a plein d'agences franchement
qui se montent et je crois que ça
cartonne j'aimerais bien faire quelqu'un
qui aime la boulangerie par exemple qui
fait des croissants je comprends mais
quelqu'un qui vit seul tout le temps qui
n'a pas de Marie comment il peut être
bon dans ce matrimoniale comme ça la
finalité tu finiras seul mais tu rendras
les gens heureux
mais je pense que franchement parfois
c'est les cordonniers les plus mal
chaussées bien sûr voilà et que c'est
pas parce que aujourd'hui je sais je
suis célibataire que je le saurai
d'ailleurs à vitamine
mais franchement j'ai j'ai ce petit truc
en tout cas j'ai créé des couples et
c'est quelque chose que que j'aimerais
bien en fait la mission impossible parce
que
et franchement je pense que je pourrais
peut-être même essayer avec des choses
pourquoi vous avez pas essayé l'agence
matrimoniale vous
c'est pas c'est vachement bien vous vous
avez qu'un petit dossier des photos
justement c'est qu'il faut mettre des
fruits je le garde non pas pour lui je
le garde est-ce que ça coûte cher ça de
s'inscrire dans ce patrimoniale
il y a un vrai suivi elle fait vraiment
une étude avec le profil votre profil
les profils des personnalités qu'elle
vous propose c'est vraiment avancer et
je propose un truc on va tous se
concrétiser on va tout ce cotiser tous
surtout vous d'ailleurs et il faut qu'on
offre ça évidemment 5000 euros
donc
j'imagine la scène imagine l'émission de
la personne qui va vous voir dans une
robe blanche
est-ce que je peux venir la semaine
prochaine avec des propositions pour
Daniel grand plaisir avec grand plaisir
tout à fait
alors n'hésitez pas à ne pas difficile
donc
sélection la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
mais oui mais alors je suis fasciné par
la suite et alors surtout il y a de la
clientèle
j'ai une copine qui habite en Suisse
elle m'a dit écoute j'ai un couple Jura
qui a ouvert une agence matrimoniale
c'est les plus riches du canton et donc
non mais c'est un truc de témoignage
en fait il ne pense pas du tout ce qui
dit en fait pas du tout
célèbres qui ont été sortis de la morgue
Serge Lama avait été dans son ex
uniquement il est au moment où il a eu
fermé fermer le le frigo le croque-mort
à deux a vu qu'il bougeait non mais
c'est pas des blagues ça c'est marrantes
c'est quoi c'est celui qui maquille
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que moi mon grand-père quand il avait un
peu trop maquillé ça fait ça fait
bizarre quand il est trop lève un peu
rouge
le maquiller quelqu'un je sais pas pour
qu'il soit beau quand la famille vient
moi ça m'a toujours fasciné file la mort
me fasse bien sûr
alors je serai chercheur d'épave
alors ça aurait pu être
moi j'aurais déjà Michel mais non
Jean-Michel
c'est ma grande passion chercheur d'or
ou chercheur d'épaves et c'est vrai
qu'il y a 3 millions de départ dans le
monde et ça représente 55 milliards
d'euros sous l'eau voilà et moi c'est un
truc qui me fascine tu m'as fait rêver
vous êtes vous êtes certifié en plongée
oui
on va faire un test
ça veut dire quoi ça ça je suis
complètement zinzin
oxygène oxygène non je suis sur la
réserve
non j'ai plus d'air j'ai plus d'air
très bien et ça ça veut dire quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ça ça veut dire quoi ok exactement
allez on y va très bien et ça c'est
je serai happiness manager
et bien oui
alors j'ai essayé la musique ça a foiré
[Applaudissements]
je suis toujours dit parce qu'en fait
j'adore chez moi au golf je suis
vraiment quand j'organise des
compétitions avec les copains j'essaie
de réunir tout le monde qui a de la joie
que tout le monde s'entende c'est ça en
fait à pince manager il réunir les gens
qui s'entendent bien autour de d'une
compétition d'un repas et ça je savais
que je sais faire j'aime bien c'est un
vrai alors il a un vrai métier il est
sauveteur il est sauveteurs en mer ah
oui bien sûr il est certifié bien sûr
j'ai sauvé des villes il a sauvé des
villes
je ne plaisante Pascal j'ai des
mouvements il est diplômé il a sauvé des
villes
on est beaucoup comme ça et je l'ai
salut tous Voilà j'ouvrirai une ferme
avec un âne avec un âne et des poules
avec un âne cette petite ferme un âne et
de poule t'es qui vont faire ça alors
Gilles non c'est pas c'est qui
c'est mon rêve j'adore alors j'adorerais
ouvrir une micro ferme avec de la
permaculture
j'ai déjà les noms et des poules
Germaine et Cunégonde voilà
et à faire un potager manger mes propres
légumes d'ailleurs je ne vais pas
attendre d'être au chômage je crois que
je vais le faire
je postulerai pour le prochain rôle de
globe évidemment ça c'est vous permettez
que je réalise mon rêve bah écoutez oui
vous le faire 30 secondes ça va en
manger non mais parce que j'ai en fait
je fais ça chez moi
vous avez déjà la tête
mais je sais alors oui vraiment le faire
là je vous en prie
[Applaudissements]
très bien
merci vous avez
Gilles franchement vous allez de mieux
en mieux vraiment c'est vraiment
beaucoup mieux